[Music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have a founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health. Dr. Joel Wall
[Music]
Hello. Hello everybody. Let's go ahead
and open up the doors. As yes, we are a
live Zoom. I just want to say hello to
our live audience as they are coming in
and also to those that are watching the
live stream or even the replay. Thanks
for being part of our community today
and I am super excited as we're going to
be dis demystifying
food.
We're going to go a little more in depth
when it comes to food. So today we are
honored to be able to host once again
the amazing Dr. Lisa Single. She is
lovingly known as the 100 pound weight
loss specialist and she is absolutely
fantastic as she is bringing her medical
experience
combining it with nutrition
and helping us help the world create a
better health journey. So folks, if you
are joining us because somebody invited
you, you want to make sure you get back
with them. Tell them what you liked best
about the program and they are your
first point of contact if you have any
questions whatsoever. We are a resource
for an amazing community of health
coaches, health advocates, people that
just know the importance of nutrition
and what it can do within the body. I
mean, we can go to the doctor and have
every single test in the world and they
won't find anything wrong with us. they
won't find it because there's over 900
different poor health conditions that
are nutritional deficiencies and they're
not looking at them. So that's what we
look at as we help people who just can't
figure it out or their doctors can't
figure it out find out what it takes to
let the body do what it was designed to
do. Now with Dr. Lisa
um she's going to be taking a deep dive
into Dr. Wallik's 12 bad foods and
demystifying
but with AI the smarter way to eat. So
without further ado, you know, Dr. Lisa,
you have such an amazing journey. I mean
you're coming from nutrition
uh from conventional medicine. Where'd
you go? There you are. You're coming
from conventional medicine. You had a
practice.
You've had health transformation through
holistic strategies.
And your personal story is just
absolutely
fantastic. I mean, it's
you you struggled with things that many
people, especially in the United States,
struggled with. I struggled with it.
And because of nutrition and those
holistic approaches, we're able to
thrive.
So, I'm super excited to hear the
lecture that you're going to be bringing
us today. Um, as you do such a great job
with your presentations
and as we're going through those 12 bad
foods,
you're going to be really diving in as
to basically why we don't want to
include them in our diets, right?
>> Absolutely.
And yes, I am Thank you so much for
bringing me back. I'm so glad to be
here. And yeah, I'm adding a little
refresh or update to the 12 bad food
story and I'm getting an assist from AI.
So, I really um I love that artificial
intelligence is able to help us so much
get the message out. And I know that I'm
speaking with a whole host of experts on
the 12 bad foods. So, um, this may be
something that will help you talk to
others about it if this is your
wheelhouse.
But there's also a challenge in there,
and I can't wait to give you the
challenge, but it's got to be at the
end, so you got to wait for that.
>> Okay. So, before you get started though,
I'm supposed to do this. This program is
for educational purposes only. It is not
meant to take the place of your primary
care physician. Nor is it meant to
treat, diagnose, or cure any disease.
But folks,
when you give the body what it needs,
because of the research
of the doctor that we have
learned to love,
who treated us like dogs, but we got
better, Dr. Joel Wallik.
We are so passionate
about spreading his message and the
truth about nutrition
on our program Daily with Doc and Becca.
And today's doc is Dr. Lisa Singleary.
So Dr. Lisa and and I also have to say
results vary and may not be typical,
but how many times Dr. Lisa, have we
helped people through nutrition and the
results are so consistent when they are
consistent?
You have just said the key word
consistency,
right? And I was actually talking with
someone earlier today and they were
asking me about a diagnosis and what
nutrition could help them. And I said,
you know,
do you really take the nutrition?
And there was a consistency problem. So
they had everything they need on the
shelf. But this is not a shelf life
situation. This is not a shelf help
program.
This is a selfhelp
program. So but the power of I I was
amazed at the power of nutrition. And
I'm going to share my story a little bit
later in the presentation,
but when I was in medical school,
um, we had four hours of nutrition.
And the only fact I can remember from
that four hours is there's six grams of
protein in an egg.
And I went for decades as a physician
thinking that was a wasted four hours. I
needed nothing. I I we've got so much
protein. We don't need to know how much
protein there is in egg. Of course, now
we're scrambling to figure out, okay,
how can we get enough healthy protein in
our bodies? It's the building block, you
know, we we weren't taught about that.
just it was it so I'm on a learning path
myself about nutrition but I'm amazed
every day at people who come back to me
and say
um when I made this change
it made such a difference
and even the change of
just cut out some of the bad foods
you know people are like everything is
so expensive
Look, I'm telling you, eat less, right?
Or spend less. So, um you cut out the
bad foods, you do a few It doesn't take
a It doesn't take a lot of um changes,
but it does take consistency.
So,
>> yes, it does. I I was speaking with a
doctor last night and she was telling me
what she just had delivered to the house
and I'm like, I'm firing myself as your
health coach because you won't listen.
And as a doctor with multiple doctor
degrees,
I just don't know what to do with you.
They're too smart for your own good.
It's so simple. So, Dr. Lisa, I'm going
to let you jump into this presentation
and share how simple it really can be
and let's find out why we want to remove
those things.
>> All righty. So, um yeah, and oh, I can't
wait to get to the challenge,
but let's jump to the presentation
first. So, I'm going to share my screen
and
I am
uh
I'm going to let me know if this is a
good uh
let me know if this is a good setup.
>> That looks great.
>> Okay, awesome.
So today is the good food, bad food
challenge. So yes, you you pro you might
know about the good foods and the bad
foods, but I've got something new for
you today to challenge you. Maybe to
make it fun, maybe something you can
share to um help teach others about the
good foods and the bad foods.
So here's the question. are healthy
foods and notice the quote unquote,
right? Are quote unquote healthy foods
actually
hurting you? And I see the
advertisements every day on TV or on
YouTube
um about different foods that are
supposedly healthy uh and they're not.
So
here's the rule number one and this
actually came from my medical training
as well. This is part of the hypocratic
oath.
Prim no first do no harm and with the
way that we eat.
It's like um fueling the fire, right?
And the fire is the fire of
inflammation.
And here's a statement I want you to
just burn or tattoo on your forehead. As
Dr. Arios would say, it's more important
to avoid the bad foods than whatever
of the good foods you want to choose.
You want to be vegan, you want to be
vegetarian, you want to be um lacto
ovarian, you want to be paleo, you want
to be carnivore, you want to be keto,
you want to be you want to follow South
Beach, Miami Beach, I don't know, all
the beaches, all the diets, the zone
diet, Mayo Clinic diet, all
every single one of those diets has
um the the
possibility or the trap or the the
sneaky
um
uh I can't think of the word but um it
has bad foods on the list. So you're I
will say there's one disease you're
diabetic and you get a diabetic diet
from your nutritionist and it tells you
to eat all kinds of bread and carbs and
um it's crazy what they put on those
those diets. So we need to watch we need
to avoid the bad foods.
Number one, enemy number one is gluten.
What is gluten? It's a protein. Now, we
know we think about proteins in our
bodies, but the structure of plants also
includes proteins. So, gluten is an
actual protein in wheat, barley, rye,
and oats. And actually they're cousins
of each other and they have different
amounts of
um
chemicals, not chemicals but uh
compounds, molecules
that our bodies may not be able to break
down. And some people have a harder time
with some of these people you've heard
of celiac disease. But no one,
no human being on the planet has the
enzymes to break down all of these
proteins. So gluten,
um, avenin, that's what it's called in
oatmeal. Um, all the different cousins
of these grasses,
they have a protein.
They need the proteins. We don't.
So, let's look at the foods to avoid.
And notice we're focusing on the bad
foods first because that's the most
important.
So, what happens? Why is gluten such a
problem? Well, here's the chain. Step
number one, poor digestion. Your stomach
and your digestive enzymes can't break
down the gluten proteins.
So what happens in your intestines?
These long undigested proteins enter the
intestines and they start to bombard the
lining of the intest intestines. And so
that causes intestinal damage.
the and not only is the um are the
intestines damaged,
it actually starts inflammation
right at the lining of the gut. And then
what happens when that inflammation is
rampant? We have something called leaky
gut syndrome.
And that leaky gut does not number one
it doesn't block the bad things that are
in the gut that are supposed to stay in
the gut but then so it allows things to
get across the gut the lining the gut
wall that are not supposed to get into
the body but it also doesn't absorb the
things that are supposed to get in. So
um there's a dual function and both of
the functions of the gut are blocked
when there's inflammation
in the lining of the gut. Also the gut
microbiome
has an imbalance of bad bacteria versus
good bacteria. Now we don't really talk
about good and bad. It's just an easy
way to think of, yeah, there are
bacteria that flourish
when we're unhealthy
and there are bacteria that flourish
when we're in excellent health or
optimal health. And they're at war. And
we want the war to tip towards the side
of the good bacteria, not the bad
bacteria.
So
you will find on almost every list of
healthy foods
olive oil, right? And different kinds of
oils. But anytime
an oil is exposed to oxygen,
it starts to go bad. And going bad isn't
just um that it's unpleasant or doesn't
taste right. There are actually
amazing bad health consequences to these
rancid
uh compounds. So we've got butter,
right? How long was butter vilified?
Ever since they made Krisco uh the you
know in bringing on Crisco in the
market, they said butter is bad, but
butter, lard, ghee, beef tallow, you
know, those are rendered animal fats.
They're natural and our bodies know
exactly what to do with those with those
items.
But what happens when
uh some
foods are exposed to extremely dry heat
and some people will ask and you've seen
the good food bad food list and people
will ask why are potato skins on the bad
food list? What's the deal with the
potato skins?
Here's the deal.
when they are roasted,
when they are fried. These are
um I'm going to use the term dry heat
methods or waterfree methods. It forms
these chemical compounds
that
become carcinogenic.
So it's not like I said it's not just uh
we should you know it's it's not a
trivial thing that we want to avoid
um fried foods and we want to avoid
roasted
and dry heat potato skins
um because these compounds form when
under the heat under dry heat.
The other big category of compounds we
want to avoid is heteroscyclic amines.
Again and um there are others the um aes
I I call them ages but they are
glycemic. They're compounds from sugars,
compounds from proteins that get um too
heated. All of these are bad.
Unfortunately, that's where a lot of the
flavor can come from. So, we have to
learn how to flavor our foods
differently in order to have an ex a
pleasing experience,
but we have to know that it's not just a
matter of taste. These cooking methods
actually cause damage.
Also, um, processed meats, ultra meats
that have nitrites, nitrates. So, deli
ham, deli turkey, bacon, pepperoni,
sausage,
all on the bad list. Now, it is
wonderful
if you could. I grew up on a farm. So I
used to come home from school and there
was a pig in the kitchen slaughtered
from stem to stern and um we made our
own sausage. I wouldn't you know it's
too much work but um it's wonderful if
you've got a local farm nearby and you
know what they're putting in there and
you know they're not taking shortcuts.
But um my goodness, what they put in our
food supply is really shocking. So we
want to avoid those bad foods.
There's another um item on the list that
people ask about and that is um
basically carbonated drink sodas
that we want to avoid those. And there's
a caveat. You mainly want to avoid them.
Well, you want to avoid them all the
time, mostly because of the sugar, but
you want to avoid them definitely
with foods because they help to
neutralize your stomach acid, which
means your stomach doesn't break down
the food as efficiently.
And that sets up the previous
issue that we talked about that um these
large molecules of food now they're
supposed to be small and become
microscopic with the digestive enzymes.
But if if they're too big hitting the
intestines, then the digestive enzymes
don't get the chance to break it down as
small as they need to be. And that is a
setup for
uh a inflamed gut.
All right, corn and soy are on the bad
food list. But guess what? It's not
because corn and soy are bad,
but it's the way they're grown. They
that corn and soy are
I don't know the percentage now. I
believe it's 95 or north%. Now things
have been sha shuffling
lately
and they say
that um there are corn and soy grown
that are not genetically modified. But
um
I'm not sure I believe them. I'll just
put it like that. So we had a we had a
point in our society, however, that more
than 90% of corn and soy were GMO.
Again, I grew up on a farm.
Ah, Silver Queen corn. Oh my goodness,
that was so good growing up. I haven't
had it in decades, but there was no GMO
in those in that Silver Queen corn. But
I noticed um when I would go back home
over the decades that I saw more and
more
labels on the fields and you know signs
and they looked official and so I read
one of the sign and the signs they're
they're experimenting
in the country right on these beautiful
fields
with GM MOC's
and I I was shocked. I was shocked. So,
cuz I live about
um
oh, an hour and a half south of
Baltimore. I mean, where this was uh 20
miles south of Annapolis in the country,
right? What are they doing with these
GMO experiments going on down there? But
they were there. And so we have to be
very very wary
of
corn and soy and anything that's
genetically modified.
And here are some samples of why.
Um, and
you know why? What's the deal with GMO?
Well, they're genetically modified so
that they can withstand being dowsted
with pesticides.
And so, they're absorbing more
pesticides than nutrients from the soil.
And that is just not a prescription
that's going to benefit our health.
All right, let's take a breath. Let's
take a deep breath.
All right. Now, let's talk about the
good foods because that's a much more
pleasant story than the bad foods. The
simple solution,
protein and produce.
Yes.
And you can, if you just stick with
that, just have that in your mind,
you're going to be so far ahead of the
game when it comes to your health,
protein
and produce.
So,
um, you have a choice.
And some people will look at the good
food, bad food list and they're like,
what can I eat? you it you have a
choice, right? So, take the list
shopping with you. Um,
just start learning about why the
different items are on one side of the
list or other. I hope today you've
gotten a little bit of um clarity on
that.
But here we go. Here's some good foods.
eggs and the yolks need to be we I'm not
talking about hardcooked
hard whether you're hardcooked and you
fried that's bad bad bad bad or
hardboiled because when the yolk is
solid that means that all the goodness
of the yolk the cholesterol primarily
has
solidified I mean it has been changed
from the natural ual absorbable form
to a um
uh
a form where the proteins have been
locked together and then that's not
absorbable not not as absorbable and it
doesn't give you the same benefit.
butter. We talked about butter, salt,
meat, poultry, fish, vegetables, fruits,
seeds, nuts. Now, no peanuts
and or I should say ground nuts because
of the moisture.
And they develop a mold called
aphletoxin or they a mold called
aspiggillis
which makes a toxin called aphletoxin
and that can cause
um some of the uh diseases we saw on the
previous list including
um types of cancer.
rice.
Now, brown rice, white rice, of course,
have at it, debate at it. The most
important thing with rice is yes, we
know that there's more nutrition in
um brown rice than white rice
theoretically, but where's the rice
uh grown, right? So, I would rather have
white rice grown from a field that's
highly mineralized than brown rice
that's grown in a field that's devoid
of natural minerals. So,
um, the most important thing with rice,
especially with this population being so
gluten intolerant, not I'm sorry, so
insulin resistant
and
diabetic or near diabetic is the amount,
right? So again, this idea of
consistency, consistently
monitoring the amount of starches that
you, even if they're healthy starches,
they can turn against you because they
are like sugars in your body. Okay,
potatoes and yams,
as long as you're not dry roasting them,
they're wonderful. put put them in
stews. Um, steam them. Uh, well, I'm a
pressure cooker girl. I love it. But
anything where there's moisture in the
cooking process, then we're okay. But
when it's a dry roast, we want to avoid,
we want to not eat the skins. Okay.
Beans, quinoa,
so many options. just be um creative
and focus on what you remove
and then things can be very simple and
very fun.
So I can't see the chat but I wonder if
you would put in the chat what's one
thing you might reconsider
on your plate. So I am Dr. Lisa
Singleary. I'm known as the 100 pound
weight loss specialist because
personally I've lost over 150 lbs and
um the number one
principle that I used was
cutting out the bad foods. Now it also
helped that I had a mindset. I had
macronutrients that was looking at the
good food bad food list. Fats, carbs and
proteins. I had the micronutrients that
I needed. I was so blessed to find a
source
of complete nutrition.
Um, I had some motion going on and I
learned the importance of measurement. I
am a retired physician. My training is
in family practice
and um I'm also now a certified holistic
health coach and I'm very blessed to be
learning the power of nutrition.
So yeah, I had a lot of motion going on
and I'm so thankful. I was a very very
heavy girl but
um I the motion I had the gift of motion
and music.
But in 2008 I left my medical practice
and I left ballroom dancing to go home
and take care of my parents
and I was their primary caretaker for
eight years. My mom was bed bound. My
father was wheelchair bound. And
something I thought I'd never do. I
never I always said, you know, in
medical school, I'm so glad I'm not a
nurse because they work so hard.
And all of a sudden, I had to be a nurse
overnight for two people that I really
cared about.
So, um, I learned a lot and it was my
privilege to do it. But by the end of
those eight years, I needed my father's
wheelchair just to get around the house.
I needed a miracle.
Now, in healthcare or in health and
wellness, we don't talk about miracles.
We don't talk about them in healthcare
either.
But this is also my disclaimer slide.
So, we've had two disclaimers today.
Becca gave a disclaimer at the jump and
I always give a my own personal
disclaimer that I'm uh even though I do
mention some diseases
because they are just
so prevalent and so impactful, so in our
faces. This is not a medical
consultation. This is not a second
opinion.
Your insurance isn't going to cover me.
Right. This is my personal experience,
my medical knowledge, my research and um
my testimony, I needed a miracle.
And then um when I turned 60 a few years
ago now, it's crazy how time is flying.
Can you believe it's September? I can't
believe it. Anyway,
uh I plotted my weight through the years
and the pattern was shocking to me. I
mean, I lived in this body all this
time, but I did not know really what was
happening to my weight. And it's been
documented in studies that Americans
tend to gain one to three pounds every
year, mostly during the winter. So,
we're heading into the danger season.
It's a wonderful time of the year, but
it's also a dangerous time for our
diets.
So, um, but I want you to see just the
trajec
trajectory
that I was on.
And even in that middle area where I
briefly,
very briefly took a weight loss drug and
I dropped some weight.
As soon as I stopped the drug,
it was just like I had never
um had lost that weight before.
And I found unfortunately
that gaining that drug, I mean, gaining
that weight back
turned me from a pair, you know, where
we carry the weight on our hips mostly
to an apple where I found all of a
sudden I had all of this midsection
weight. And I learned the lesson. When
you have yo-yo dieting and the weight
goes away and it comes back, it doesn't
come back in the same place, especially
if your hormones are out of balance. So
that was a very hard lesson for me to
learn. But over there in letter B,
something happened and it was wonderful
because I started learning the power of
nutrition.
And I learned how to what what I learned
helped me to go from the picture on the
left to the picture on the right. and
still on my journey today, but I'm in so
much better shape because of nutrition.
So, here's the challenge,
and this is good for even if you already
know all about the 12 bad foods. Do you
really avoid them? So, here's a
challenge, and I made an app, and this
is the first page of the app.
Um, it's 21 days.
Can you avoid the bad foods for 21 days?
And it's just a yes or no.
Sorry.
I um I avoided them today. So, one day
at a time.
And if you hit that button, start my
challenge. Now, I can't see the
navigation at the bottom, but there's a
navigation there. And we're going to the
uh check-in page. And so, once a day,
you just check in. Did you successfully
avoid all 12 bad foods today? And if you
hit yes,
then you get the little digital
celebrations. Yeah. Yoohoo. And
actually, there's a message like, you
know, keep going. Great job. and it
tracks your streak.
And at 7 days, at 14 days, and at 21
days, you get uh again digital
celebration. It's really a neat little
app that um uh AI helped me make.
And in there, we list the 12 bad foods.
Actually, there more than 12 on the
list, but you get the idea.
And if you, this is a cool thing, if you
tap on any one of those tiles,
you can see why those foods are
considered bad foods. So fried foods
create harmful
pro-inflammatory compounds, those
acryumides and heteroscyclic amines.
and the uh seed oils oxidize easily
things we've talked about, but you can
do that for every single one of these
categories. Well, we also do it for the
good foods. So, um and again, you can
tap the tiles. So, I tap dairy, beef,
poultry, fish. They are high quality
proteins and nutrients.
And I tap the healthy fats, the nuts and
seeds, healthy fats and clean
carbohydrates.
And you can have this app, too. So, all
you have to do is pull out your phones,
scan this QR code, and I invite you to
take the 12 bed food challenge. Can you
go
21 days
without
consuming any of the bad foods and
documenting your journey every single
day and you know if you miss a day the
streak it starts over from day one. So
you have to do it every day and that
helps you to build the habit right. So,
um I would love to hear from you how you
um like the app or um if you find that
it helps you to stay on point just a
little bit more cuz yeah you you make
that you have a choice to make things
are presented to you but ah I don't want
to break the streak so it just you know
little gamification helps you to stay on
point. So, I hope this app helps you to
learn about the good foods and bad
foods, but also to stay on track. So,
like I said, just scan this QR code or
go to
drlisary.online/badfood
challenge, but put some hyphens in
there. So, it's bad hyphen food hyphen
challenge.
Alrighty.
So, I have another invitation for you.
On Saturdays, I do a series on YouTube.
Well, I do it on Zoom on Saturday
morning
um at 11:00 a.m. Eastern called the
Total Transformation Secrets live Zoom
series.
And um I thoroughly invite you to
register at drlisary.online. online
slashlive
zoom or scan this QR code.
And what happens is on Saturday evenings
at 900 p.m.
I put the same the replay of the morning
on YouTube and the first YouTube showing
is our premier watch party. Um,
and I you maybe you could tell me. I I
sometimes I think uh I just want to put
it on YouTube right away. I don't even
want to wait for the watch party. So,
but um we're together
right now for the premieres
uh on Saturday evenings at 900 p.m.
Eastern.
Alrighty.
So, woo.
Are you ready to take the challenge?
>> I'm ready to take the challenge. I
already went to the app. I already
logged today because I continued to be
compliant with consistency.
Um, which I mean this doctor I was
talking to, she's like, "Tell, be
honest, Becca. Are you really
do you really always eat right?
And I'm thinking
except for the sugar part
when I go to New York and AJ drags me to
the gluten-free pastry shop.
>> Blame it on AJ.
>> It's his fault. But yes, I mean it's not
hard to follow the good foods bad foods
list. No.
>> And the and I think the key point is
when you go shopping, just don't buy
anything on the bad foods list. Stock
your cupboards, stock your refrigerator
with, like Dr. Lisa said, proteins and
produce.
And you know, I've like you grew up on a
farm. We were surrounded by farms. Even
now in Pennsylvania, there's corn
everywhere.
And I'm afraid to eat it.
I really am because there's there's so
much that they use to treat the corn
seed
>> to help keep the weeds from growing
in the ground. How can that not be in
the food that it produces?
Not only that, this the thing that
worries me is all of a sudden now these
labels non-GMO
come up like where where were the
fields, right? Where'd you get these
where'd you get these organic
fields? And if they're right next to or
you know downwind of a field that gets
sprayed for crops, they're getting the
pesticides just on the wind.
Uh, and even dry farming when it rains
and if if you've got a field downhill
>> Exactly.
>> or downstream even from a field that's
not
using organic practices, you're going to
have contamination.
>> Well, I also think I always think of
Farmer Glenn
>> um Schultz was his last no
>> Schultz. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Farmer Glenn Schultz and his story
when he decided to turn this
dirt, this solid dirt field into a lush
soil
um that would produce organic
um crops and he went to the
um what do they call he went to the
government basically in the area and
they said, "All right, well, first thing
you do is you just shock the whole area
with pestic with Roundup like you just
you know double triple quadruple the
Roundup the for the and then till that
in
>> and then you can start your organic
farming. is like that's completely
against the whole reason I'm trying to
do like did you hear me didn't you hear
me say organic
but that was there
>> and you
were talking about shelf life earlier
you spray that ground it's going to stay
in the ground
>> it's going to stay
>> for more than a few minutes or years
>> absolutely
>> I I just you know my dad always told me
one man's common sense is not that of
another.
>> Oh,
>> powerful. Powerful. Well, Dr. Lisa, we
do have a few questions.
And Barbara is wanting to know. She
says, "Uncccured bacon says it has no
nitrates or nitrites. Is it okay to
eat?" Now, I know on packages that I've
looked at, it says no added nitrates or
nitrites.
What is your response?
>> Um,
here's what they do. Uh, they take they
don't put it in labeled as nitrates or
nitrates, but they will put in I'll bet
if you look on the package, you'll see
celery extract or celery, you know,
dried celery or some kind of celery uh
component. And the reason they do that
is celery is the number one absorber of
nitrites from the soil. So what they do
is they put the nitrites on the celery
and then they put the celery in the
food chain. And the
that is one of the
um crazy practices of the FDA that they
can label it as celery. They don't have
to label it as added nitrates. So they
get it in there. Now I would kind of ra
rather have nitrates from celery than
from wherever they got them before. So
um you know
good, better, best.
I'm sure we used something on the farm,
you know, that may not have been the
best thing as well, but it was
definitely closer to natural than uh
that. So, read the labels. Yes. Don't be
fooled. Yes. Make decisions, but make
them knowing
that it's not a it's not um 100% cut and
dry situation.
And if I can add to that, when you're
cooking bacon, if you do choose
in on the bad foods list, it says no
burnt fats.
Bacon is primarily fat. So, if you're
going to be cooking bacon, cook on low
heat and don't make it extra crispy,
folks.
>> Yeah,
>> because that's burnt fat.
>> Absolutely.
The next question, Ann is asking, "Is it
okay to roast a potato without the
skin?" She says, "I usually peel and
cube a sweet potato and roast with
butter and pink salt.
When it starts to caramelize, when it
starts to turn brown, then that you're
making those compounds." So, um, no,
>> no. And folks,
>> and I mean, if
>> French fries,
>> if toast,
right, if bread were okay, and there are
people that uh, do have gluten-free
bread now. Now,
I can't even read the labels of some of
those gluten-free breads myself. They
they put so many other chemicals in them
to try to make them breadlike.
But um a slice of gluten-free bread
tastes so much better if you toast it,
right? But that process of toasting
makes those compounds.
>> Yeah. So if you're going to be warming
your bread, don't get it brown.
Just warm enough to melt that butter.
Just enough.
>> Just enough. Fantastic. And let me see
if there was another question here. And
folks, if you have questions, go ahead
and type it into the chat, whether
you're here live with us or out on one
of the platforms. We do have people that
are watching those platforms bringing
those questions in. Olga wants to know
and this is coming from YouTube. She
says most soy is GM O grown. Rice is
often grown in fields where cotton is
grown and it's not organic cotton. Then
rice cannot be organic either which is
correct.
>> Correct.
So again, that's where we really need to
read those labels, check the sourcing.
Um, I even go to the point of looking to
see where those fields are grown if I
can. Oh, sorry. Olga was on Rumble. And
folks, that brings up something.
Go to Rumble, look up Daily with Doc,
look up Critical Health News. And if you
don't have a Rumble account, create one.
It's well worth it. We currently are
banned on YouTube because Dr. Wallik
said something that was truth,
but there you go. So, make sure you
follow us on Rumble. Thank you, Olga,
for being out there on Rumble and asking
the question. Um,
now
Oh, and Ann, um, thank you, Dr. Lisa.
pressure cooker. It is. I'm a pressure
cooker gal, too. I have stepped up to
the Insta Pot
>> with the pressure and the slow cooker
and all of it in one. So, what is your
favorite protein and produce meal?
>> Okay. But first I want to say this
because
um
even if we do everything possible,
we can't ensure that we're 100% avoiding
all of the I mean we breathe them. It's
it's in the air the you know things we
need to avoid electromagnetic overwhelm.
um so many things. We're exposed. We're
embedded. We're in a toxic soup of an
env environment.
And
that means our bodies have to step up to
the plate. And we do have detoxing
systems in our body.
And when we have all the essential
nutrients, they can function.
So
um
yes uh sometimes I I won't say sometimes
I am not as dogmatic as doc about a lot
of things
just because in my mind I'm like how how
can we actually say
we're avoiding these things and it's not
because we don't try But we can't always
I mean we read the labels but we have we
can't always trust the labels.
um we read the signs, we you know, but
but if our bodies have all of the
minerals that we need to to fuel to
trigger all of the enzymes
and the enzymes have all of the proteins
that they need to do their job and all
of the co-actors that they need, the
vitamins and the amino acids.
We are in such a better place than if we
are nutritionally deficient. Our cells
know what to do when they have and and
they can do what they know what to do
when they have all of the essential
nutrients.
So I say that to say
it's yes, it's a lot to read labels.
It's a lot to just live knowing that all
of these chemicals are around and things
like that. But
if we focus on giving our bodies what
they need, then our bodies know what to
do. So take the stress off,
get the nutrition in.
But
>> here's the question of the hour, Dr.
Lisa. Can we get all the nutrition we
need from food?
[Laughter]
That was a trick question. So,
um, if we rolled back the clock to
200 years ago
and we just got food sources from
specific places around the earth, then
the answer would be yes. But
all of the minerals that we need are not
uniform
uniformly distributed in the crust of
the earth. There are whole states that
don't have selenium in the soil.
Right? Just like gold
is in a gold mine is in a vein.
All the other minerals are like that
too. So yeah, there's some people that
are in what they call blue zones.
There's some people they got lucky just
geographically
and they're in wonderful
um in places that have wonderful soil or
a volcano erupts nearby and yeah, it's
terrible with the lava and everything,
but the ash from the volcano has so many
minerals and so there are areas I'm
thinking of the Pacific Northwest right
now,
you know, where the soil is amazing and
I I remember the first time I saw an
apple from Washington State. I was I was
amazed. Right. So,
um but with those rare exceptions, the
answer is no. Those essential nutrients
have to be taken in strategically.
And um I'll say a bit about the word
essential. Essential. When you when you
think of essential
there are actually three meanings.
One that we're not discussing today is
essential oils and that word is from the
word the essence. So the the essence of
the flowers and the barks and the leaves
and whatnot. We're not talking about
that. That's not the essential we're
talking about.
The second word for essential means you
need them.
I think everyone can understand that.
But the medical,
biochemical, biomedical, anatomical,
physiological
meaning of essential and this is very
important is that your body cannot make
them.
So, the only way to get these 90
essential nutrients
is to take them in.
And good luck trying to get them from
food.
>> No, you have to supplement.
>> So, Dr. Lisa,
Youngevity has made it simple.
We can get the right
nutrients
in the right dose
at the right time of day
to completely support
the body, all of the um enzyme,
all of the metabolic functions of the
body. And it's such a blessing.
>> And that includes mental health.
Absolutely.
Absolutely. I actually I was talking to
someone the other day.
Um she made a video for me actually
about the fact that
she's been on supplements for two and a
half years.
And
just for those two years, she did not
need medication for her seasonal
depression.
And that was a complete surprise to her.
I, you know, I certainly didn't say your
seasonal depression is going to go away
if you take I didn't know she had it.
Right. So, um, but she, that was, that
was part of her testimony that, you
know, she she didn't have trouble when
the darkness
um became prevalent throughout the the
winter. Um she said for 40 years she
needed u medication to get through and
then for the two years she did not.
>> That's fantastic.
That's fantastic. Well, Dr. Lisa, we are
at the top of the hour. Thank you so
much once again being Doesn't it go
fast? It's like you're having fun and
you time just gets away.
But and you know, you bring you bring
such a colorful joy to the program.
I love your butterflies. I love all the
colors. Um but I love the message
>> the most.
>> Thank you.
>> And the way that you deliver it. So
folks, you know, go back and watch this
program again
and make sure that you're thinking about
the bad foods and eliminate them. But
focus on those good foods because there
are so many good foods, you're not going
to starve
at all.
And if those of you who, you know, have
a hard time finding foods that you
trust, grow your own.
Make sure you're adding the bloom and
minerals to your soil. I've got some
raised beds here. I have a farm in
Washington State.
And whenever I saw the
methods of farming around me, because
I'm surrounded by thousands and
thousands of acres of dry farming,
And Dr. Wallik asked me the first time,
"Well, what do they grow?
Wheat, barley, rye,
triric,
canola for oil." He's like, "Well, you
got to move."
>> Well, I moved, but the farm is still,
you know, in my name. Um, somebody else
can deal with that. But, um, it's just
amazing. I didn't want to grow there
when I saw what they were spraying
overhead because that was going to be
getting into my food.
>> That's right.
>> And then I was very very meticulous
about the whole house filter. We were on
a well and when I tested that water, it
was high in sulfates and sulfites.
So, I wanted to make sure that we got
those filtered out, which that's a hard
one to filter out in my research,
>> but it's not impossible.
So, folks, I hope that you were able to
grab some useful information in today's
programming in helping you make wiser
decisions about the food that you put in
your home. Not just on the plate in
front of you or in your mouth, but in
your home. Dr. Lisa, thank you so much.
>> Thank you, Becca.
>> Back at you. I love you. You know, we're
almost close enough to meet up and get
that hug. It's been too long.
>> Absolutely.
Absolutely.
>> Well, if I could get our co-hosts up on
the screen with us. I am so thankful I
don't have to do this all by myself as I
have an amazing team that helps with all
the moving parts of doing the program
and the stream. Well, I am doing some of
the streaming here and the hosting, but
they are setting everything up and
making sure everything runs smoothly and
I just appreciate them so so very much.
as today we have with us Albert joining
us from South Africa. Um he is also part
of our phone team. So folks if you are
not working with somebody that you and
you've never tried any of the products
longevity products or you are looking
for a a better health journey
through supplementation that we have
found to be solutions.
Um, you are welcome to call the call
team at 855-9493377.
If you're in the States and you're a
night owl and you call, chances are
you're going to hear an amazing South
African accent.
Don't hang up on him. He is a great
great guy. So, thank you Albert for all
that you do. And also on our phone team,
actually all these people here are on
the phone team. We have Marilyn Um
Marilyn is absolutely fantastic. She's
putting notes in the chat. She does
amazing dictation. She's an amazing
researcher and writer and super excited
to have her. We want to um also
I I want to say that all of my team that
I have here with me are certified
holistic health coaches. They have gone
through the coaching program as Dr. Lisa
did um that's offered by the Institute
of Holistic Health where they have taken
Dr. Wallik's philosophies,
the four areas of health, how they're
affected by nutrition and the
deficiencies that are linked to Dr.
Wallik found over 900 poor health
conditions linked to nutritional
deficiencies. And they've also
incorporated the other seven areas of
health that include your mindset, the
finances, relationships. It's just an
amazing program, folks. And you can find
out more information about that by going
to coach.dailywithdoc.com.
Um, but back to Marilyn. Thank you so
much, Speedy Fingers, as she does such a
fantastic job putting the notes in the
chat. And we also have Sherry, who's
part of my tech crew here and sometimes
a guest on our show as she is sharing
some of her passion. is not only a
certified holistic health coach, but a
certified um health coach with an other
organization and also an herbalist
who just loves fermenting. And as she
has um moved away, I think it was
because of the last, you know, 2020
ordeal, moved away from doing live
classes, she's now sharing those up. Are
you telling me to speed up, AJ? Oh, it
okay. But she's also doing um live
classes here for us and helping us to
learn the benefits of fermented food.
And last but not least, we have AJ, who
is our digital marketing director. He's
been very helpful in getting us on the
different platforms and he he also keeps
track of my mail that I don't get to. um
where we found out that we were banned
on YouTube for a week. But besides that,
he has been very instrumental in helping
us get the word out and also using
technology
and AI
um to create some very inspirational
videos and and tools to help us help
you. So, thank you AJ for all you do.
Folks, my name is Becca Dukes. I am a
certified naturopathic practitioner,
certified holistic health coach, and
also the director of student services
for the Institute of Holistic Health.
And it is my honor and privilege to
provide this resource to this community.
And if you're watching, you're part of
the community. I don't care where you
are located. We invite you to get
involved. Get back with the person that
shared this program with you. If you
have any desire to help others find a
better health journey and some people
like a thank you check, some people love
a thank you check. Those thank you
checks are available for sharing this
information. So get back with a person
that shared this program with you. Um it
can also be a thriving business if
you're looking for something to do on
the side, something full-time, something
to do in retirement.
There are opportunities available. If
there's nobody for you to get back with,
give us a call. 8559493377.
Dr. Lisa,
thank you for sharing your Saturday
calls with us. So folks, if you didn't
scan that code, you got to wind back,
find that code, get registered, and also
the app, the challenge.
Are you sticking to the good foods and
avoiding the bad?
It's just consistency and take your
nutrition.
So until next time everybody, this
program is sponsored by dailywithdoc.com
where you will find a good foods bad
foods list. You'll find more articles in
regards to what you can do to empower
yourself to make health decisions and
um a store for those who are not already
working with somebody or if you know
your longevity customer ID and password
that store is available there for you as
well. AJ what did I miss sir?
Well, we have a guest tomorrow and we
want to remind people if they want to uh
uh see the show live on the platforms,
they can go to uh stream.dlywithdoc.com.
They can also go
uh
>> live.withwithdoc.com.
But also, if they want to join us in the
Zoom room going forward, they need to
send an email zoomaily.com.
And maybe you could tell us about our
guest tomorrow.
>> And tomorrow we have pharmacist Ben
Fuches where he is going to be taking
your questions.
as a registered pharmacist, he is very
much into nutrition and using food as
medicine rather than chemicals. So super
excited to have pharmacist Ben on with
us tomorrow folks join us again as we
are here Wednesday, Thursday, Friday
from 12 to 1:00 p.m. Pacific, 1 2
mountain, 23 central and 3 to 4 Eastern.
And if you're in South Africa, it's 9 to
10 or 10 to 11. We can never remember.
10 to 11. Um, in South Africa, which I
think is the same. Am I wrong?
>> It's 9 to 10.
>> 9 to 10. I said it right the first time.
>> Okay. It changes. It changes. Why can't
we just all be the same? Nah, we're
unique and special. Everybody have a
fantastic day. Be empowered and don't
forget.
You're awesome.
Bye for now.
[Music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have a founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health, Dr. Joel Wallik.
[Music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have a founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health, Dr. Joel Wallace.